- Did you charm your way
into a superstar's Broadway, like their,
their dressing room one
time when you were 10?
- Oh, yes I was 10 years old
living in--
- This is bold for 10.
- I was bold, still am.
- This is bold for 30.
(audience laughs)
- You don't,
- Yeah.
- you don't get to
you know, where I am
- Yeah.
I appreciate it.
- without being bold.
- I respect it.
- You know what I'm saying?
So I'm 10 years old,
want to be a child actor,
I'm living in Dayton, Ohio,
(audience member cheers)
there's nothing happening.
It's the mid '70s.
- You had one whoo.
- Had one whoo, nothing happening.
(audience laughing)
Whoo who
- Oh whoo.
- Dayton, Ohio, whoo?
(Audience laughing)
And I see Liza Minnelli's luggage,
says Liza Minnelli in a stencil.
And this is like Cabaret time.
She's like it.
- Oh my gosh.
- This is like her at her height
and I go to the front desk.
"What room is Liza Minnelli in?"
And they told me!
What were they thinking?
I'm like a 10 year old boy.
- Did you pretend like you were family?
- I just, I don't know what I did.
I just flat out asked
- and I went up
- [Kelly] Wow.
- and knocked on the door
in the middle of the day and
she answered in a bathrobe.
(audience laughs)
- What did you say?
- Hi, my Rob Lowe and I wanna be an actor.
- Oh my god.
(audience applauds)
- What else do you say?
I'm like what, what?
- Right?
- Was she nice?
- Oh my god.
She was awesome.
She invited me into the room.
She was there with her then husband
who is the Tin Man's
son from Wizard of Oz.
Yeah, Jack Haley, Jr.
- Yeah.
And they were,
I now realize from an adult perspective,
what they were probably up to
considering it was the middle of the day.
And they were in robes
and eating chocolate
and drinking red wine.
- Just living there,
living their best life.
- They were living their best lives.
But they were so nice to me
and Liza was fascinated
and wanted to know why I wanted to be an,
She was awesome.
- That's so cool.
- And then fast forward to 35 years later,
I'm sitting in the front
row at the Hollywood Bowl.
While Liza's performing
and now we're friends
and like I've had a big
breakthrough its amazing.
- What?
(audiences claps)
- Yeah it's crazy.
That's the coolest story
- Yeah.
- Like what a fantastic first time
for a kid, their experience.
- I know.
- That's amazing.
She was the best it was really cool.